The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: -- that this is not
a quick clicker question, so
you actually need to maybe write
something down to figure
out the answer.
So if you haven't clicked in
yet, or if you want to change
your answer, keep in mind that
you might need to jot down,
for example, a Lewis structure
before you can answer this
question.
-- and get in your final answer
to the clicker question.
For those of you just walking
in now, you might not have a
chance to get all of the thought
process that you need
in on this clicker question,
because it is based on a Lewis
structure, so we will
go over it.
But for those of you that have
been here for 30 seconds or
longer, see if you can get
the right answer in here.
All right, so OK, it looks
like we have a very mixed
response in terms of
the answer to the
clicker question today.
Raise your hand if you didn't
have time to figure out the
Lewis structure.
OK, so that accounts
for some of you.
Let's go over the correct
answer this question.
So, who got the right answer --
31% of us.
This is not the kind of
percentages we're looking for,
so let's go over this.
In class on Monday, we did go
over the geometries, and the
geometries themselves are very
straightforward, once you know
what the Lewis structure is, but
remember, you can't just
always look at a molecule
and automatically
know the Lewis structure.
We actually need to think about
those valence electrons.
So, here we're dealing with
selenium hydride, so s e h 2.
I told you that there's 6
valence electrons in selenium,
so we have 6 there, plus 1
for each of the hydrogen.
So what we should have is
8 valence electrons
in our Lewis structure.
How many electrons do we need
to have full valence shells?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 12, that's right.
We need 8 plus 4 is 12
for full shells.
That means that we need 12
minus 8, or 4 bonding
electrons in our structure.
So I tried to give you one that
you could draw pretty
quickly, it just has
hydrogens in It.
So we have s e h 2.
We can do our 4 bonding
electrons.
How many valence electrons
do we have left?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 4, that's right.
So, we need to fill our octet
for selenium, so 1, 2, 3, 4.
So, this is our Lewis structure
here, hopefully you
can see why it's not linear.
If it were linear, which 32% of
you seem have thought, that
would have meant that our Lewis
structure had no lone
pairs in it, right, and
that's not the case.
We have two lone pairs, so if
we thought about what the
bonds were everywhere,
it would be 109 .
5, but it's bent because we're
only looking at the bonds,
we're not counting the Lewis
structures in naming our
geometry, but they do
affect the angles.
And it turns out that it's
actually less than 109 .
5, because those lone pairs
are pushing the bonds even
further away.
So, does this make sense to
everyone if you think
about it this way?
Pretty much, okay.
So, we'll try another clicker
question like this later.
Some of these questions that
look very straightforward just
naming the geometry, you have
to remember to do the first
step before you jump in and
go ahead with a naming.
So you'll got plenty of practice
with this on your
problem-set if you
haven't already.
All right.
So before we start in with
today's notes, I do want to
mention that this morning
the Nobel Prize in
chemistry was announced.
This is an exciting week in
science in general because we
got to hear another
Nobel Prize every
morning pretty much.
So, let's settle down for a
second and start listening.
All right.
So, today we're going to be
talking about molecular
orbital theory, but first I
wanted to just mention, in
case some of you didn't hear
what the Nobel Prize was this
morning, and this was in
chemistry, it went to three
different chemists.
Osamu Shimomura, who's a
Japanese chemist, and then
Martin Chalfi who's at Columbia,
and Robert Chen
who's at U. C. San Diego.
The three of these chemists
split the Nobel Prize this
morning for their discovery
and/or their application of
using green fluorescent
protein, which
is also called GFP.
How many of you have heard
of GFP before?
Oh, that's so great.
OK.
Many of you have heard of GFP.
For some of you that haven't
I'll just say that it's a
protein, it's 238 amino acids,
which means that it's about
1,000, actually more than 1,000
atoms in size, and this
protein is fluorescent.
The protein was first discovered
and first isolated
from this jellyfish here.
This was done by Shimomura,
and he did this in
the 60's and 70's.
He actually recognized and, of
course, many people recognized
that this jellyfish was
fluorescent, and he isolated
the actual protein, and
determined and proved that
this protein was sufficient to
cause this fluorescence.
So, in terms of thinking about
applications of why it's so
exciting that you have this
fluorescent protein, other
than it's always really fun
to look at things that are
fluorescent, we can think about
in terms of biology why
it's so exciting, you can
actually tag this protein to
any other protein that you're
studying and now you have a
visual handle on what's
going on.
So, for example, if you were
interested in some protein
involved in cancer, you
could tag it with GFP.
You could watch where it
localizes in the cell, there
are fluorescent assays you could
use to determine what
other proteins it
interacts with.
You could see, for example,
when it's expressed in a
cancer cell, and where
it's expressed.
There are all sorts of things
you can do once you can
visualize something
with fluorescence.
The reason it is so exciting
that it's a protein, and it's
a protein, this is the structure
here, it's a ribbon
structure so you can kind of see
what it looks like, it's
made up of all natural
amino acids.
So this means we can code for
it in DNA, you don't have to
worry how am I going to
get into the cell.
All you have to do is mutate
the DNA, which is very
straightforward to do in
molecular biology, and now you
can tag absolutely any protein
that you're interested in.
So, as I said, this was first
discovered and isolated from
the jellyfish.
This was done by Shimomura --
that was kind of the first
step in this process of having
it become such a useful tool.
And then, many years later,
not until 1994 did Martin
Chalfi, at Columbia, show that
yes, I can, in fact, take the
DNA and put it into a different
organism, and he put
it into e coli, a bacteria.
And what he could show was that
it could be expressed,
this is a picture from his 1994
science paper, in that e
coli, and it is going
to fluoresce green.
Now, the first application
tends to not be quite as
exciting as, for example, all
the other organisms people
have put it in since then --
you can have flies, you see
transgenic mice that are glowing
green with this GFP.
Of course, that's not the useful
application for it,
it's more of a proof of
principle, but it does show
you that you can put it in for
studies in any organisms.
And the field was really
pushed forward by the
discoveries of Robert Chen at UC
San Diego, and what he did
was he actually figured out how
it was that this protein
fluoresced, what caused the
actual fluorescence.
And once he did that, both he
and many other scientists,
could then, once they understood
what caused the
fluorescence, make little
changes to the actual protein,
and tune what the properties
of that
fluorescent protein were.
So now, for example, there are
a whole range, just a whole
rainbow of fluorescent proteins
that can be used.
And I'm sure you can imagine
that if you want to label onw
protein green and one red and
one yellow, now you can start
looking at really complex
biological processes.
So, it's pretty rare that
chemistry makes
the every day news.
So hopefully you'll all look
in the normal papers today,
not just the scientific
journals, and get to read
something about chemistry.
It's always fun to see how its
described in The New York
Times or in The Boston Globe.
The other thing I wanted to
mention and I'm not sure if
the exhibit's still there.
But there was an exhibit of
jellyfish, I know at least
until last year, at the Boston
Museum of Science, and all of
you guys can get
in there free.
And it's neat to see the glowing
jellyfish and think
about the fluorescent protein
that's in them.
So, I encourage you to do that
the next time you have some
free time on your hands, maybe
at IAP or some time like that.
All right, so let's move
into today's notes.
Today we're talking about
molecular orbital theory.
This is a shift, this is a new
topic that we're starting.
So far we've exclusively been
using Lewis structures any
time we've tried to describe
bonding within molecules.
Lewis structures are really
useful, we use them all the
time in chemistry.
And they're useful because,
first of all, they're easy to
depict, they're easy to draw --
relatively easy once we get
all the rules down.
And also they're accurate
over 90% of the time.
But they're not accurate all the
time in predicting bonding
within molecules, and the reason
for this is because
Lewis structures are
not, in fact,
based on quantum mechanics.
So, molecular orbital theory, on
the other hand, is based on
quantum mechanics.
And specifically, MO theory
is the quantum mechanical
description of wave functions
within molecules.
So, saying wave functions within
molecules might sound a
little confusing, but remember
we spent a lot of time talking
about wave functions within
atoms, and we know how to
describe that, we know that a
wave function just means an
atomic orbital.
It's the same thing with
molecules -- a molecular wave
function just means a
molecular orbital.
So, we'll start today talking
about the two kinds of
molecular orbitals, we can
talk about bonding or
anti-bonding orbitals.
Then we're going to actually
use MO theory to describe
bonding within these molecules,
and we'll start
with homonuclear diatomic
molecules.
Diatomic mean it's di atomic,
it's made up of two atoms, and
homonuclear means that those two
are the same atoms. Then
at the end, we'll look at an
example with a heteronuclear
diatomic molecules.
So, again, the same thing, but
now two different atoms.
So, I will point out, in terms
of MO theory, because it
rigorously does take into
account quantum mechanics, it
starts to become complicated
once we go
beyond diatomic molecules.
So we're going to limit in our
discussion in 511-1 for
molecular orbital theory
to diatomic molecules.
However, on Friday we will use a
different approach so we can
talk about bonding within atoms
that have more than two
atoms, molecules with
more than two atoms.
All right, so one thing that I
first want to point out about
MO theory that is a big
difference from Lewis
structures, is that in MO theory
valence electrons are
de-localized over the
entire molecule.
So, when we talked about Lewis
structures, we actually
assigned electrons to individual
atoms or to
individual bonds.
Whereas in molecular orbital
theory, what I'm telling you
is instead we understand that
the electrons are spread all
over the molecule, they're not
just associated with a single
atom or a single bond.
So specifically, what we do
associate them instead is
within molecular orbitals, and
what we say is that they can
be either in bonding or
anti-bonding orbitals.
And again, I want to point out
that a molecular orbital, we
can also call that
a wave function,
they're the same thing.
And these orbitals arise from
the combination of individual
atomic orbital.
So, if we have two atomic
orbitals coming together from
two different atoms and they
combine, what we end up
forming is a molecular
orbital.
The reason that we can talk
about this is remember that
we're talking about wave
functions, we're talking about
waves, so we can have
constructive interference in
which two different orbitals can
constructively interfere,
we can also have destructive
interference.
So, we'll start by taking
a look at constructive
interference, and another way to
explain this is just to say
again, molecular orbitals
are a linear
combination of atomic orbitals.
So, let's start our discussion
of a bonding orbital.
Our simplest case that we can
look at would be if we had two
1 s orbitals coming together.
So let's say, for example,
in a hydrogen atom.
So in hydrogen atom a, I'll
depict that here where the
nucleus is this dot, and then
the circle is what I'm
depicting as the
wave function.
It makes sense to draw the wave
function as a circle,
because we do know
that 1 s orbitals
are spherically symmetric.
So, we can say that a circle is
a good approximation for a
1 s wave function.
Similarly, with the second
hydrogen atom, we've got the
nucleus in the middle, and the 1
s b wave function around it.
So these are atomic orbitals.
What we're going to do in
forming a molecule is just
bring these two orbitals close
together such that now we have
their nucleus, the two nuclei,
at a distance apart that's
equal to the bond length.
And what we end up forming is
a molecular orbital, because
as we bring these two atomic
orbitals close together, the
part between them, that wave
function, constructively
interferes such that in our
molecular orbital, we actually
have a lot of wave function
in between the two nuclei.
So we can go ahead and name our
molecular orbital, just
like we know how to name
our atomic orbitals.
And I'm going to name
this sigma 1 s.
The 1 s just comes from the
fact that the molecular
orbital is a combination of
two 1 s atomic orbitals.
And the sigma tells us something
about the symmetry
of this molecular orbital,
specifically that it's
cylindrically symmetric
about the bond axis.
So that is the bond axis -- it's
just the axis between the
two nuclei.
Sometimes it's also called
the internuclear axis.
So any time you have two atoms
bonding, the bond axis is just
the axis that they're
bonding along.
Another thing I want to point
out about every sigma orbital
that you see, and it will make
more sense when we contrast it
with pi orbitals later.
But in sigma orbitals, you have
no nodal planes along the
bond axis, so if we had a nodal
plane here, we'd see an
area where the wave function
was equal to zero.
We don't see that.
It will make more sense when we
can show you one where it
does have that area.
But keep in mind sigma orbitals
have no nodal planes
along the bond axis.
All right.
So, let's look at this in
another way, sometimes it's
hard to picture these
waves combining.
So let's think of them a little
bit more by graphing
the amplitude of the wave, and
seeing how we can have this
constructive interference.
So again, if we think of a graph
of the wave function, we
had the wave function is at
its highest amplitude when
it's lined up with the nucleus,
and then as we got
further away from the nucleus,
the amplitude of the wave
function ends up tapering off
until -- it never hits zero
exactly, but it goes
down very low.
So we can draw that for 1 s a,
we can also draw it for 1 s b,
and what I'm saying for the
molecular wave function is
that we have the interference
between the two, and we have a
constructive interference, so
we end up adding these two
wave functions together.
So, we're talking about wave
functions and we know that
means orbitals, but this is --
probably the better way to
think about is the physical
interpretation of the wave function.
So what is the wave function
squared going to be equal to?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Probability
density, yes.
Probability density of finding
an electron within that
molecule in some given volume.
So let's think about that
instead, let's think about
probability density.
So if we're talking about
probability density that's the
wave function squared.
But now we're talking not about
an atomic wave function,
we're talking about a molecular
wave function.
So to talk about it's squared,
we're going to say it's sigma
1 s squared.
Oh, and actually before you skip
your page in the notes, I
realized I should write out for
you what the addition is
to start with.
So, when we're combining two
waves, what we have is 1 s a
that we're adding together
with 1 s for
b, the second atom.
And what we end up for
our molecular wave
function is sigma 1 s.
So this is what we call
our molecular orbital.
All right, so that will now
allow you to turn the page, I
think, and we can take a look
at the probability.
So the probability again,
that's just the orbital
squared, the wave function
squared.
So when we write that out, we
just write sigma 1 s squared,
or we can break it up into its
individual parts, there's no
reason we can't do
that as well.
So just to say that it's 1 s
squared plus 1 s b, all of
that together squared.
So if we write out every term
individually, what we end up
with is essentially just the
probability density for the
first atom, then the probability
density for the
second atom, and then we have
this last term here, and this
is what ends up being the
interference term.
So in this case where we're
adding it together, this is
going to be constructive
interference.
So in this case the cross term
represents constructive
interference between the two
1 s atomic wave functions.
And this again is what
we're going to
call a bonding orbital.
So it can often make a lot more
sense if we think about
things in terms of energy.
We've been discussing energy
diagrams a lot in this class,
it's a very good way to
visualize exactly
what's going on.
So, let's think of the energy
of interaction when we're
comparing atomic orbitals to
molecular bonding orbitals.
And what you find is when you
have a bonding orbital, the
energy decreases compared
to the atomic orbitals.
So you can see here in this
slide we have the atomic
orbitals for the two hydrogen
atoms, each of them have one
electron in them, hydrogen has
one electron in a 1 s orbital.
So, if we look at the molecular
orbital, that's
actually going to be lower in
energy than either of the two
atomic orbitals.
So it's going to be favorable
for the electrons instead to
go to that lower energy
state and be within
the molecular orbital.
So, let's draw in our electrons
there, so we have
our two electrons now in
the molecular orbital.
So any time that you're drawing
these molecular
orbital diagrams, you want to
keep in mind that the number
of electrons that you have in
atomic orbitals, you need to
add those together
and put that many
electrons into your molecule.
Right, we had one from each
atom, so that means we need a
total of two in our
molecular orbital.
And what you can see directly
from looking at this energy
level diagram, is that the
molecule that we have is now
more stable in the individual
atoms. That makes sense
because we're lower in energy,
the electrons are
now lower in energy.
So that's the idea of a bonding
molecular orbital.
Since we're talking about wave
functions, since we're talking
about the properties of waves,
we don't only have
constructive interference, we
can also imagine a case where
we would have destructive
interference.
Just like we see destructive
interference with water waves
or with light waves, we can
also see destructive
interference with orbitals.
So, let's think about what
that would look like.
So in this case we would have
1 s a and 1 s b, and instead
we would subtract one from the
other, and what we would see
is that instead of having
additional, more wave function
in the middle here, we've
actually cancelled out the
wave function and we
end up with a node.
So we can also name this
orbital, and this orbital
we're going to call
sigma 1 s star.
So if we name this orbital,
this is an anti-bonding
molecular orbital.
So we had bonding and now
we're talking about
anti-bonding.
When we talk about anti-bonding,
essentially
we're taking 1 s a and now we're
subtracting 1 s b, and
what we end up with again is
sigma 1 s, and the important
thing to remember is to
write this star here.
So any time you see a
star that means an
anti-bonding orbital.
Again we can look at this in
terms of thinking about a
picture this way, in terms of
drawing the wave function out
on an axis.
So we have 1 s a, and we're
drawing this as having a
positive amplitude, but since
we have destructive
interference we're going to
draw 1 s b as having the
opposite sign, so we
have a plus and a
minus in terms of signs.
So that should make it very easy
to picture that this is
being cancelled out
in the middle.
If we overlay what the actual
molecular orbital is on top of
it, what you see is that in
the center you end up
cancelling out the wave
function entirely.
So this is the 1 s star, sigma 1
s star orbital, and what you
have in the center here is a
node, right in the center
between the two nuclei.
So again if we look at this
in terms of its physical
interpretation or probability
density, what we need to do is
square the wave function.
So if we square sigma 1 s star,
we flip the amplitude so
it's all positive now, but again
we still have this node
right in the middle.
So if we talk about the
probability density and we
write that in, it's going to be
sigma 1 s star squared, so
now we're talking about
1 s a minus 1 s b, all
of that being squared.
And again, if we write out what
all the terms are, we
again have 1 s a squared plus
1 s b squared, but now what
we're doing is we're actually
subtracting the
interference term.
So if we're subtracting the
interference term, what we
have here now is destructive
interference.
So let's think about the energy
of interaction here.
When we were talking about
constructive interference, we
had more electron density
in between the 2 nuclei.
So that lowered the energy
of the molecular orbital.
So, bonding orbitals
are down here.
But when we think about where
anti-bonding orbitals should
be, it should be higher
in energy.
It's increased compared to
the atomic orbitals.
So we would label our
anti-bonding orbital higher in
energy than our 1 s
atomic orbitals.
So, let's think a little bit
about what this means.
First of all, again to repeat,
any time we see the star,
sigma 1 s star, that's an
anti-bonding orbital.
When we talk about that,
basically what we're saying,
and you can see that because of
that negative interference,
we actually have less electron
density between the nuclei
than we did when they were two
separate atoms. So you can see
that this is non-bonding,
this is even worse than
non-bonding, it's anti-bonding,
because we're
actually getting rid of electron
density between the
two nuclei.
And we know that it's electron
density between the nuclei
that holds two atoms
together in a bond.
So what I want to point out is
that it creates an effect that
is exactly opposite of a bond.
You might have thought before
we started talking about
molecular orbital theory that
non-bonding was the opposite
of bonding, it's not,
anti-bonding is the opposite
of bonding, and anti-bonding
is not non-bonding.
We can see that if we just look
at this picture here.
Here is bonding, and here
is non-bonding.
Anti-bonding is even higher in
energy than non-bonding.
And the other thing to point out
is that the energy that an
anti-bonding orbital is raised
by, is the same amount as a
bonding orbital is lowered by.
So any time I draw these
molecular orbitals, I do my
best, and I'm not always
perfect, yet trying to make
this energy different exactly
the same for the anti-bonding
orbital being raised,
versus the bonding
orbital being lowered.
So those should be raised and
lowered by the same energy.
So now let's take a look
at some of -- is there
a question up there?
STUDENT: Why would two atoms
decide to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, they
don't want to.
It's a higher energy
situation.
So we'll start to look at
molecules and we'll see if we
take two atoms and we fill in
our molecular orbital and it
turns out that they have more
anti-bonding orbitals than
bonding, that's -- a diatomic
molecule we'll never see.
So it helps us predict, will we
see this, for example, h 2,
which we're going to be about to
do, we'll see is stabilized
because it has more bonding
than anti-bonding.
So we'll predict, yes,
there's a bond here.
That's a really good question.
So, let's go ahead and do this
and take a look at some of the
actual atoms that we can
think about and think
about them in molecules.
So our simplest case that we
started talking about was
molecular hydrogen.
I want to finish this discussion
by including the
anti-bonding orbital, and this
is a tip for you when you're
drawing your molecular orbital
diagrams, any time you draw a
bonding orbital, there is
also an anti-bonding
orbital that exists.
It might not have any electrons
in it, but it still
exists, so you need to draw
these into your molecular
orbital diagram.
So I wanted to make sure you
have a complete set for
hydrogen in your notes.
So let's take a look at this.
Hydrogen, we can first draw
in our atomic electrons.
So there's one electron
in each hydrogen atom.
And then this means we'll have
a total of two electrons in
our hydrogen molecule, so we
can fill both of those into
the sigma 1 s orbital,
the bonding orbital.
We don't have to put anything
into the anti-bonding orbital,
so that's great.
What we've seen is we have a net
lowering of energy of the
molecule versus the
individual atoms.
So let's draw the electron
configuration of hydrogen, the
molecule, molecular hydrogen.
What you saw, what we've done
a lot of is drawing the
electron configurations for
different atoms, we can do the
same thing for a molecule.
So, if we take h 2, and we
want to draw the electron
configuration, it's
very short.
All it is sigma 1 s, and then
we have two electrons in it,
so it's sigma 1 s squared.
So this is our electron
configuration.
Let's take a look at
another example.
Let's draw the molecular
diagram for h e 2 now.
So again, we can fill in our
atomic orbitals here, there's
going to be two electrons in
each of our atomic orbitals.
So now let's go ahead and fill
in our molecular orbitals.
We need to fill in a total
of four electrons.
So we have two electrons in
our bonding orbital, but
because we use the same rules to
fill up molecular orbitals
as we do atomic orbitals, so the
Pauli exclusion principle
tells us we can't have more
than two electrons per
orbital, so we have
to go up to our
anti-bonding orbital here.
So this means that we have two
of the electrons are lowered
in energy, but two are
raised in energy.
So would this be a stabilized
molecule then?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
So, compared to the atoms, it
should be somewhat the same
energy, we shouldn't get any
extra stabilization from
forming the molecule.
So lets go ahead and write
what the electron
configuration would
be of h e 2.
And again, we're just filling in
the different orbitals, so
we have sigma 1 s, that's going
to be squared, and now
we have sigma 1 s
star squared.
So we can compare the two
electron configurations, and
we can actually think about --
what we figure out from them,
we see that two are lowered in
energy, two electrons are
raised in energy, so we have no
net gain or no net loss in
energy for h e 2.
And there's actually a way that
we can make predictions
here, and what I'll tell you
is molecular orbital theory
predicts that h e 2 does not
exist because it's not
stabilized in terms of
forming the molecule.
The way that we can figure this
out is using something
called bond order, and bond
order is equal to 1/2 times
the number of bonding electrons,
minus the number of
anti-bonding electrons.
And the bond order you get out
will either be, for example,
zero, which would mean that you
have no bond, or you could
have 1, a single bond, 1 .
5, a 1 and 1/2 bond, 2, a
double bond, and so on.
So let's figure out the bond
order for our two molecules
here that we figured out the
electron configuration for.
So I guess we'll start
with helium 2.
So the bond order is going to
be equal to 1/2, and then it
will be 2 minus 2.
So our bond order for h e 2
is going to be equal to 0.
So it has a 0 bond, there's
no bond in h e 2.
Let's look for hydrogen.
For hydrogen our bond order is
going to equal 1/2, 2 minus 0.
So we would predict
a bond order of 1.
What kind of a bond is
a bond order of 1?
Yeah, we'd expect to see a
single bond in hydrogen.
So what actually turns out the
reality is that h e 2 does
exist, but it exists as the
weakest chemical bond known,
and it wasn't, in fact, even
found to exist until 1993, so
I can assure you this is not a
bond that you see very often
in nature, and it is a
very, very weak bond.
It only has a dissociation
energy of 0 .
1 kilojoules per mole.
So that should make sense,
because we saw no energy
difference between the actual
atoms and the molecules.
Molecular orbital theory, even
at this very basic level,
allowed us to predict that no,
we're not going to see a true
bond here, a strong bond.
In contrast, the dissociation
energy of a bond for hydrogen,
and molecular hydrogen is
everywhere around us, we see
432 kilojoules per mole.
All right, so we can now see a
little bit of what the power
of molecular orbital theory is
in predicting what kind of
bonds we're going to see in
molecules, or whether or not
we'll see this bonding
occur at all.
So let's look at another
example, let's take lithium 2
and see what we can
figure out here.
In lithium 2, we have two atoms
of lithium, each have
three electrons in them.
So now we have to include both
the 1 s orbitals and also the
2 s orbitals.
So any time in a molecular
orbital diagram you draw in
orbitals, you need to draw the
corresponding molecular orbitals.
So, this means we need to have
sigma 1 s, sigma 1 s star, and
now sigma 2 s and
sigma 2 s star.
Something I'll also point out
as you see these dashed line
that tell you where the
individual molecular orbitals
are arising from, as you get
to higher and higher atomic
numbers of molecules that you're
making, it makes a lot
more sense to look at a diagram
when you draw these
dotted lines in, because
they can start to get
a little bit confusing.
So when you go ahead and draw
these on your problem-sets or
on your exams, it's a good idea
to put these dashed lines
in, both for you and for people
reading it to see
exactly where your molecular
orbitals are coming from.
So, this means we have a total
of six electrons that we need
to put into molecular
orbitals.
So again we just start filling
those up -- we have two in the
1 s, two in the sigma 1 s star,
and then we have two in
the sigma 2 s.
So we should be able to also
calculate the bond order, just
like we did for hydrogen
and helium.
First we can do that by
knowing the electron
configuration, we can write it
out just by going up the table
here, up the energy levels.
And you can go ahead and tell
me what you think the bond
order is going to be
for this molecule.
All right.
Let's take 10 more
seconds on this.
OK, good, we're back on
track a little bit
with our clicker answers.
So it's selection three or
one is the bond order.
So let's switch back to our
class notes and look at what
this means.
So we know that it's 1, because
we have 1, 2, 3, 4
bonding, minus 2 anti-bonding,
and 1/2 of that is a bond
order of 1.
We would predict to see a single
bond between lithium,
and it turns out that's
what we see.
And so you have for a reference,
the dissociation
energy of lithium 2 is 105
kilojoules per mole.
So let's keep moving along the
periodic table and keep
applying our molecular
orbitals.
For example now, with b e 2,
so beryllium 2 has four
electrons in terms
of each atom.
So you can start by filling
those in, and now we can fill
in our molecular orbitals
as well.
This means we need a total
of eight electrons in our
molecular orbitals.
So we have two in 1 s, two in
the sigma 1 s star, two in the
sigma 2 s, and two in
the sigma 2 s star.
So let's go ahead and figure
out the bonding order for
beryllium here.
So when we figure it out for
beryllium -- let's see if I
wrote in your notes what
the actual -- electron
configuration, OK that's already
in your notes for you.
So let's go right to the bond
order for beryllium.
So for the bond order we want
to take 1/2 of the total
number of bonding electrons, so
that's going to be 4 minus
anti-bonding is 4, so we end up
getting a bond order that's
equal to 0.
So what I want to point out with
this case in beryllium is
that you don't have to use all
of the electrons to figure out
the bond order, and in fact,
once you get to molecules that
are from atoms with atomic
numbers of 8 or 10, you're not
going to want to maybe
draw out the full
molecular orbital diagram.
So what I want to tell you is
we also always get the same
bond order if we instead
only deal
with the valence electrons.
So let's just prove that to
ourselves and figure out the
bond order just using
valence electrons.
So this would mean the bond
order is equal to 1/2, and in
terms of valence electrons,
how many bonding valence
electrons do we have?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, what
about anti-bonding?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Two.
OK, good.
So again, we're going to
see that we have a
bonding order of 0.
So we would not predict
to see a b e 2 bond.
So what we see is a bond order
of 0, and again, the bond is
very, very weak.
Essentially we're not going
to see this, it's 9
kilojoules per mole.
All right.
So, so far we've looked only
at molecules that involve
atoms that have only
s orbitals in them.
I'm sure you're thinking well,
what do we do in the case of p
orbitals, and, in fact, we
can do the same thing.
Again, we're going to take the
linear combination of those p
atomic orbitals and make what
are called pi or some more
sigma molecular orbitals.
So let's look at the first case
where we have either the
2 p x or 2 p y type of orbitals
that we're combining.
So they're the same shape,
this is the shape of the
orbital or the shape of the wave
function, and we can call
this either 2 p x a being
combined with 2 p x b, or we
could say since it's the same
shape, it's 2 p y a being
combined with 2 p y b.
And in either case if we first
talk about constructive
interference, what again we're
going to see is that where
these two orbitals come
together, we're going to see
increased wave function in
that area, so we saw
constructive interference.
So again, we can name these
molecular orbitals and these
we're going to call -- also to
point out there is now a bond
axis along this nodal plane,
which is something we didn't
see before when we were
combining the s orbitals.
So when we go ahead and name
these, we're going to call
these pi orbitals.
We'll call it either pi 2 p x,
if we're combining the x
orbitals, or pi 2 p y.
The reason that I wanted to
point out this nodal plane
here is because this is why
it is called a pi orbital.
Pi orbitals are a molecular
orbital that have a nodal
plane through the bond axis.
Remember this is our bond axis
here, and you can see there is
this area where the wave
function is equal to zero all
along that plane, that's
a nodal plane.
So that's why these
are pi orbitals
instead of sigma orbitals.
So again, we can think about
the probability density in
terms of squaring the
wave function.
So now what it is that we're
squaring is if we're talking
about x orbital, it's pi 2 p
x squared, and this is just
equal to the 2 p x a plus the 2
p x b all squared, or if we
write out all of the terms we
have 2 p x a squared plus 2 p
x b squared, and then this term
here, and again, this is
our interference term.
In this case is it constructive
or destructive
interference?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Constructive
interference.
We're seeing that the wave
function's adding together and
giving us more wave function
in the center here.
All right.
So we see constructive
interference, of course, we
can also see destructive
interference.
So I changed the colors here
to show that these are 2 p
orbitals with an opposite phase
or an opposite sign.
So what happens when we add a 2
p a and we subtract from it
a 2 p x b, or the same with a 2
p y a subtracting a 2 p y b,
is that we're actually going
to cancel out the wave
function in the center, so we
now have 2 nodal planes.
So again, this is an
anti-bonding orbital, and what
you see is that there is now
less electron density between
the two nuclei than there was
when you had non-bonding.
So we're going to call this the
sigma 2 p x star, or if
we're talking about the 2 p y
orbitals we'll call this the
pi 2 p x star, and the
pi 2 p y star.
And the pi star orbitals result
from any time you have
destructive interference from
2 p orbitals that are either
the p x or the p y.
So now we can move on to an
example where we do, in fact,
have to use some p orbitals,
so this would be b 2.
How many electrons
are in boron?
Five.
I see some hands going up.
There's five electrons So what
you'll notice here is that I
only filled in 3 electrons.
What do these electrons
represent?
STUDENT: Valence.
PROFESSOR: Valence electrons.
OK, sometimes you're going to
be asked to draw a molecular
orbital diagram where you're
asked to include all
electrons, and sometimes it
will specifically say only
include valence electrons.
That happens because of space
issues that you were asked to
do that, because you can always
assume that all of the
core orbitals are already
going to be filled.
So, in this case, we're just
drawing the molecular orbital
diagram for the valence
electrons, so we
have three for each.
And what we see here is now when
we're combining the p, we
have our 2 p x and our 2 p y
orbitals that are lower in
energy, and then our pi
anti-bonding orbitals that are
higher in energy.
You might be asking where the 2
p z orbital is and we'll get
to that soon once we need it.
Let's just first fill in
this for the b 2 case.
So we can start at the bottom,
two electrons in sigma 2 s,
two electrons in
sigma 2 s star.
Now we need to jump up to using
these pi orbitals, and
what we're going to do is put
one electron into each of our
pi 2 p x and 2 p y orbitals.
So again you can see as we're
filling up our molecular
orbitals, we're using the exact
same principle we used
to fill up atomic orbitals.
So let's think about what
the valence electron
configuration is here.
So now we're looking
at the case of b 2.
And what we're looking at is a
valence electron molecular
orbital diagram, so let's
just draw the electron
configuration for the valence
orbitals, so that will be
sigma 2 s 2, sigma 2 s star 2,
and now we start in with our
pi 2 p x 1, and our
pi 2 p y 1.
So this is our valence electron
configuration for b 2.
All right.
So what would you expect the
bonding order for b 2 to be?
Shout it out if you know.
STUDENT: one.
PROFESSOR: And I didn't write up
there but it is one, and we
can see that it's 1, because
it's 1/2 of 2, 4 minus 2, so
1/2 of 2, the bonding order is
going to be equal to one.
So let's move on to another
example, let's talk about
carbon here.
Again, we're just talking about
the valence electrons.
So carbon has four valence
electrons, so if we talk about
c 2, again we're going to start
filling in our molecular
orbitals, and now we're going
to have eight electrons to
fill into our molecular
orbitals.
So, we'll put two in the sigma
2 s, two in the sigma 2 s
star, and now we're going to
fill one and one into each of
our pi 2 p x and 2 p y, but we
still have two electrons left,
so what we're going to do is
double up in terms of our 2 p
x and our 2 p y.
So let's think about what this
valence electron configuration
is for c 2.
And again, I want you to have
practiced drawing these out in
the form -- you always need to
start with the sigma and then
write the number
of the orbital.
So, sigma 2 s has two electrons,
sigma 2 s star with
two electrons, and now we have
sigma 2 p x -- how many
electrons here?
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
And sigma 2 p y, two
electrons here.
Oh excuse me, pi 2 p y, thank
you -- pi 2 p x and pi 2 p y.
So let's talk about what
the bonding order is
going to be for c 2.
So what's the bonding
order for c 2?
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: two?
OK, so we have 2, 4, 6 minus 2,
so we have 1/2 of 6 minus
2, so that's 1/2 half 4, so we
have a bonding order of two
for carbon 2.
So we would expect to see a
double bond for a c 2 where we
would expect to see a -- double
bond for c 2 and a
single bond for b 2.
And that is, in fact, what we
can surmise if we look at the
different dissociation energies
for the two bonds.
So for b 2, which is a single
bond, that's 289 kilojoules
per mole to break it, and it
takes us more energy to break
this double bond for carbon,
which is 599
kilojoules per mole.
So, in general what we see,
and this is always true if
we're comparing the same atom,
and in general, if we're
comparing different types of
molecules, but we know that a
single bond is always weaker
than a double bond, which is
weaker than a triple bond.
And obviously, no bond is the
weakest of all is not bonding.
All right.
So let's look now at the case
where we do have 2 p z
orbitals that we're
talking about.
So again, what we're talking
about is the linear
combination of atomic 2 p
orbitals, and now we're
talking about 2 p z.
So if we have constructive
interference between the two,
what we're going to see is our
molecular orbital looks
something like this.
Do you predict that this will
be a sigma or a pi orbital?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, I'm
hearing a little of both, but
I'm very encouraged to
hear quite a few
people saying sigma.
This is, in fact, a sigma
2 p z orbital is what
this orbital is called.
The reason that it's sigma is
if you look at the bonding
axis here, is that there
is no nodal plane
along the bonding axis.
Also, it is cylindrically
symmetric around the bonding
axis, so this is how we know
that it's a sigma orbital.
So some p orbitals form pi
molecular orbitals, and some
form sigma p orbitals.
Specifically, it's always the
z that forms the sigma
orbital, and the reason is at
least at a minimum for this
class we always define the
internuclear axis as the z
axis, so this is always the z
axis, so it's always going to
be the 2 p z's that are coming
together head-on.
The reason that there is
increased electron density
here is you can see that these
two orbitals come together and
constructively interfere.
We can also talk about
anti-bonding orbitals where we
have destructive interference.
So instead, these would be
canceling out wave functions
between the two, so we would end
up with a nodal plane down
the center.
Would this be a sigma or a pi?
It's still sigma.
So even though we see a nodal
plane down the center, I just
want to really point out that
it's only when we have a nodal
plane in the internuclear or
the bond axis that we're
calling that a pi orbital.
So this is still a
sigma -- it's a
sigma 2 p z star orbital.
We have destructive
interference here.
So now let's look at an example
where we talk about
using these 2 p z orbitals,
so let's look at oxygen.
So the first thing I want to
point out is that the 2 p z,
the sigma 2 p z is even lower in
energy than the pi orbitals
here, and the anti-bonding sigma
orbital is going to be
higher in energy than the pi 2
p orbitals that we have here.
So in oxygen again, this is
just showing the valence
electrons, so we end up having
six valence electrons from
each oxygen atom.
We can fill right up our table
just like we did before, but
now we have included our
2 p z orbital here.
So we have two electrons in
sigma 2 s, two in sigma 2 s
star, in sigma 2 p z we have two
-- those are filled first,
and now we're going to put
one into pi 2 p x, and
one into pi 2 p y.
So we can write out what the
electron configuration is
here, and I think that I have
already written that out for
you in your notes.
What is the bond order of o 2?
It's two.
Oh excuse me, I didn't fill
in all of my electrons.
All right.
So we had a total
of 2, 4, 6, 8.
So we had a total of 12.
So we filled in four here --
we need to keep going.
All right, so I did this not at
all purposely, but this can
point out for you that you need
to make sure that the
number of electrons that you
have in your molecular orbital
does match up with the total
number that you have in your
atomic orbitals.
So I did not do any counting up
here, you should make sure
you do counting, I apologize.
So we need to fill all the
way up to the pi 2 p x,
and the pi 2 p y.
All right, so the bonding order,
you're correct, should
be 2, if we subtract the
number of bonding minus
anti-bonding electrons
and take that in 1/2.
And what I want to point out
that we just figured out for
molecular orbital theory, is
that o 2 is a biradical,
because remember, the definition
of a radical is
when we have an unpaired
electron.
You can see that we have two
unpaired electrons in this
molecule here -- one in the pi
2 p x star, and one in the pi
2 p y star orbital.
This was something we could
not predict using Lewis
structures, but we can predict
using MO theory that we have a
radical species here.
So that's a really important
type of an application that we
can use MO theory for that we
weren't able to do with our
Lewis structures.
All right, I want to do one more
at homonuclear example
here, and this is n 2.
The first thing that I need to
point out is you can actually
see an n 2 versus o 2 that we
flip-flopped the energy of the
sigma and the pi 2 p orbitals.
So this is a glitch, just like
sometimes we had glitches in
filling up our atomic
orbitals.
This is something that
you need to remember.
And what you need to remember is
if the z is equal to eight
or greater, such as oxygen being
the cut-off point, this
sigma 2 p orbital is actually
lower in energy than the pi 2
p orbitals, the molecular
orbitals.
But for anything 7 or
less, so what is the
atomic number for nitrogen?
STUDENT: Five.
PROFESSOR: five -- there's five
valence electrons, but
the atomic number is
actually seven.
So z equals 7 -- this is the
cut-off where, in fact, the
sigma orbital is going to be
higher in energy than the pi 2
p orbitals.
This is something that you
just need to remember.
I wrote it down your notes, if
you can put a big star next to
it so you don't forget this.
This is something you're going
to be responsible for in
drawing out your molecular
orbitals.
So let's fill it out in this
way, keeping in mind that
we're going to fill out the
pi 2 p's before the sigma.
So we have a total of 2, 4, 6,
8, 10 valence electrons, so
I'll make sure I count to 10
as we fill up our molecular
orbitals here.
We have two, then
we have four.
Now we're going to start in
with that pi 2 p orbitals,
which gives us 1 each, and then
two each in those, and
then after that, we'll go up
to our sigma 2 p z orbital.
So this is going to be our
molecular orbital diagram.
And again, I've written for you,
but you can figure out
what the electron configuration
is just by
writing up in this order here.
And what is the bond order
going to be n 2?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's going
to be three.
So, you can go ahead and
calculate that, if you can't
see that right away.
So we'll end here, we'll
finish up with the
heteronuclear example
on Friday.